all right guys
bang bang lunch money time while while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
is trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here
with pelina who looks like an angel
today or an
artist i'm not sure yet haven't decided
intel maybe
but don't forget that lunch money is not
sponsored by block fi go get a block fi
account 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can buy and sell crypto on the
crypto exchange or you can deposit
crypto and take out a us dollar loan
against that crypto collateral go check
them out blockfy.com
pomp again blockfy.com pomp
what's up hey what are we doing i don't
normally wear makeup on the show but i
have a thing after this so i gotta like
okay all right
the people like me as i am just all
right first time claims for unemployment
insurance continued their decline last
week
hitting another pandemic era low in a
sign that the labor market
is gradually improving
but what it doesn't account for is
people who were
kind of dropped out of the labor market
completely right
uh well uh narrative violation they're
lying
they're lying they're lying here's why
they're lying
it's because 700 000
people filing for first-time
unemployment claims
would be one of the highest weeks of
unemployment claims
in history before this year i think the
highest ever was around uh
800 000 and no 800 000 was the highest
before 2020
uh and now we have seven hundred
thousand this is one of the worst weeks
for first time unemployment
in the history of the world outside of
this year it's just that relative to
earlier this year when we had
six plus million people file for first
time claims
it doesn't look as bad so everyone's
positioning as like it's getting better
it's getting better it's gonna be no
it's not
but seven hundred thousand people just
follow the first time unemployment
true but on the bright side at least
it's declining instead of going the
opposite direction
it's because we ran out of people we
literally ran out of people
there's so many people who filed for
unemployment that we ran out of people
to file for more unemployment
this is not the ongoing claims right so
this is the trick that all of these data
points show
ongoing claims would say oh there's six
million people but now some people got
their jobs back so now there's five and
a half then there's five then there's
four then there's three million two
million one million and you bet oh
people are going back to work because
it's going down
that's not what this data point is this
is first time unemployment claims
it means that they've never filed for
unemployment before and they're just now
doing it saying it's going down just
means that
literally we ran out of people there are
55
million americans one-third more than
one-third of the u.s workforce
has filed for unemployment we've run out
of people to file for unemployment
it's not that it's getting better it's
just literally everyone else already
filed for unemployment they lost their
jobs
go ahead some of the hottest
private consumer tech companies are
rushing to file their ipo prospectuses i
love reading those
so they can go public before the end of
the year airbnb
doordash roblox and wish are all
expected to make their final links
public
by early next week so here's what's been
so interesting
because if you watch past lunch monies
when the pandemic first started
all these companies were pumping the
brakes on oh my god we're not going to
go public this year because of or
who knows what covert is going to bring
and now somehow it's a good year to go
public
well when the stock market was going
down you didn't want to step in front of
a steamroller
right but now that the stock market's
going up going again the rocket ship
like
it's just basically what you're looking
for is uh
earlier this year it was an investor
market right in march when everything
was falling and there was a bunch of
uncertainty
investors hate uncertainty companies
don't want to go public in an uncertain
time
and so everyone's like whoa stop let's
not do this because we're going to get
crushed in the market let's wait well
now that all of a sudden you've got this
massive recovery in stock prices uh and
it's gotten frothy again
you're seeing people whether it's
through um
spax whether it's direct listings
whether it's the traditional ipo they
all want to get in the public market so
that they can actually raise capital or
benefit
from that stock price appreciation makes
sense yep
airbnb is going to crush it i'm an
investor come on
come on i did not know that um bitcoin
passed 16 thousand
which it hasn't done that in three years
i remember three years was 2017 right
2017
it crossed over went from 10 000 to 20
000 in 18 days
it only sat at 20 000 for less than 72
hours
so when you look at any sort of metric
around
uh 200-day moving average or any of that
stuff bitcoin's at an all-time high
the only price point that it is not at
an all-time high
is in u.s dollars in the spot market and
it only lasted above 16 000
for like less than 20 days so it's a
pretty big deal
and it feels much much stronger right
now and
it would not surprise me that we keep
does it feel stronger because there's
more people and more institutions and
more people like stanley druckenmiller
not drunken mueller
uh making public expressions about it or
why is it stronger this time
i think there's three things right so
one is there's lots more infrastructure
in place so it's easier for people to
get access
to custody um all that kind of stuff two
is
time and education so people spend more
time and more learning they understand
the asset more
uh 63 of all bitcoin haven't moved in
the last 12 months meaning that
the higher educated you are about it the
more likely you are to have strong hands
and not want to sell it which therefore
leads to kind of
uh more support underneath the price and
then the third thing is
uh the way that the price is
appreciating right now is a much
healthier way it's not like it's going
from ten thousand to twenty thousand in
eighteen days that's obviously some sort
of
again frothy market here what we're
getting is a much more kind of slow
grind up
and that slow grind up is because
there's more and more assets flowing in
uh or capital flowing into the asset uh
and so that's likely to be
uh less about pure speculation and much
more about long-term investors you know
what it reminds me of like when somebody
wins the lottery and suddenly gets a lot
of money versus someone who builds their
way up to that kind of money one is
healthier than the other
absolutely ready yep bridgewater's
dahlia ray dalio
sees governments banning bitcoin should
it become
material he told yahoo finance that
uh he said i today said he expects more
digitized versions of government issued
currencies in the future than bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies for three
reasons
one he said i today can't take my
bitcoin yet and buy things easily with
it
two bitcoin another cryptos are too
volatile he says to be considered
effective stores of wealth
and three if bitcoin or other cryptos
become material
he predicts governments will outlaw it
they'll use whatever teeth they have
to enforce that bitcoins outperformed
ray dalio
okay but but what about the government
which by the way means i've outperformed
ray daly
what about the government aspect the
whole idea that
a lot of these guys look at is yes from
a currency perspective they are correct
that the fiat currencies are going to
get digitized
of course but the part of the analysis
that they miss is that when everything
is digitized and it sits in a digital
wallet
and you are able to switch in and out of
currencies incredibly easy
the friction for switching will be
reduced
and therefore right now if i want to
take my dollars and go get let's say the
euro
i literally have to go to my bank or i
have to go to like
the the scam artist uh currency
exchangers in the airport which by the
way are complete scams
they rip you off but in the in those
situations
high friction to switch between
currencies here what happens is now with
the click of a button i can go from
bitcoin to digital dollar to digital yen
to digital euro
back to bitcoin into some other currency
whatever and so when you have that
switching cost red
uh the friction reduced now all of a
sudden people are going to allow capital
to flow
to the soundest money so what they'll do
is doesn't matter what currency they get
paid in
they'll then move to the strongest
soundest money which is bitcoin
they'll store their wealth there and
then if somebody says hey you know what
i don't accept bitcoin they said cool
what do you accept and at the point
of uh payment they can then switch back
again with a click of a button
from bitcoin to digital dollar then pay
and so what ends up happening is you're
gonna see
bitcoin just become this vacuum of
capital it's just gonna
suck value to it from all these other
currencies
because it is the soundest money the
problem with gold in the
in the kind of the analog application of
digital uh or uh sound money principles
is that the switching cost is so high if
i want to go from dollars to gold and
then from gold back to dollars
i can't do it at the point of payment
but when everything is digitized
the switching cost is so low that it's
going to happen so quickly
and so yes actually the digitization of
these other currencies is not negative
for bitcoin it's a positive
it's going to drastically increase the
adoption of digital wallets it's going
to drastically increase
the ability for people to use these
digital currencies it's going to
familiarize people with it and
ultimately what's going to happen
is that ray dalio is going to look like
a not so smart guy
because of this radar is a smart guy
he's a very very smart guy great book
wrote principles should go read all of
his stuff
uh he really understands the macro
economy he understands the economic
engine like all this stuff
he's missing the boat here on this one
and it's because
he actually has identified the right
drivers of what's going to happen
he's missing the conclusion and i think
part of the issue is he's looking at it
from an investment standpoint not from a
technology
yes but i think that somebody like ray
dalio his job is to
stay on top of like regulation and
governments and like how is this going
to affect the business long
term depending on what the government
does so i
no ray dalio's job is to make money for
his investors and he hasn't done a good
job of doing it
all right okay it's just a fact ray
dalio you're welcome on the podcast
um sure a research team lost 18
oh my god it's all weather fund he's by
the way he's one of the best investors
of all time
i'm just pointing out the fact that like
facts are facts go ahead
let me tell my stuff a research team at
deutsche bank proposed that people pay a
five percent tax for the privilege of
working from home
if they continue to do so after the
pandemic as this could subsidize income
lost by lower earners due to the corona
virus crisis in
um in a report published they say that
uh basically working from home meant
that many people were saving on everyday
costs such as travel lunch clothes and
cleaning
as well as possibly spending less on
socializing however the report also said
it meant remote workers were
contributing less to the infrastructure
of the company while still receiving its
benefits
what you corporate
thieves your thieves
why would you pay people less money yeah
for for
working from home it doesn't mean you're
spending less on lunch let me tell you
that or
close let me tell you that no we just
what is the point of what do you pay
people based on
their consumption or do you pay people
on based on their production right
of course you pay them on their
production that's a weird thing
corporate
thievery that's what that is come on
and here's the worst part it's deutsche
bank
but it's just the fact that like they
would even think about this they would
say this out loud like this is one of
those ideas that you say
when you think about it or you sit
behind closed doors somebody somewhere
is like hey we probably shouldn't say
that out loud
and these idiots went wrote a whole
report on it
okay oh wait is this right
uh-oh yeah i think it's right i think
it's right
one second yeah that's right ford motor
expects its new all-electric transit van
to help it hold on to its lead in the
commercia in commercial vans
as new and long-time competitors enter
the emerging market the vehicle is
designed for commercial and work buyers
and it's all electric it looks kind of
cool it's like a little sprinter van
life
yeah it's way better than you ever seen
those pictures of the vans where they're
like hey kids i have candy
the ford e transit commercial van will
start at under 45
000 when it arrives in dealer showrooms
in late 2021 who do you think the target
here is who who is buying these vans
i'm thinking that maybe we should buy
one and drive around the country
with like a bed in the back and you make
a little little breakfast area little
kitchen shower i just go in the water
like in the lake okay yeah
or go in a gym you can go in the gym we
can just get like a crunch membership
and drive around the country or we could
get one
have you seen you know the alex honold
thing where he like has a thing on his
van and he just does pull ups on it
finger pull-ups
finger pull-ups on that on that bar we
can get one of those
but then you don't need to take a shower
what finger pull-ups are you gonna do
oh you know i'm very i have a lot
upper body strength what is next okay
we're not getting a van
the electric vans look cool probably
going to be used for delivery and other
things
delivery is what the okay right answer
was okay i have a question i think this
one's for you but the next one
okay dylan this is ask lunch money time
if you have a question
ask lm in the comments below we will
answer
dylan wills hey pomp crowd
sorry pump crowd love the content being
created young millennial
looking to get further along financially
so much information nowadays on
invest in index fund gold silver other
commodities bitcoin other cryptos real
estate
i understand it depends on my intent and
my personal responsibility to choose
i'm pretty liquid with about 50 to sixty
thousand dollars
looking to get into investments best to
start getting into investments
wait any thoughts thanks for the info
dylan
there's four rules spend less than you
make
have multiple streams of income get out
of
inflationary assets like the dollar and
get into
real assets or investments and fours be
patient and disciplined
and for you the fourth one is the most
important here because it sounds like
you you've got
cash to invest if you've got cash to
invest you're likely spending less than
you make
hopefully you've got multiple sources of
income and
the whole key is don't go and just put
all of your money into something all at
once yeah right
being disciplined and dollar cost
averaging into investments
means that you don't have to be the
smartest person in the room are there
people who can pick market tops and
bottoms and is this a good time is this
not a good time
of course but you're much better off
just saying okay here's the asset
allocation i want right
and asset allocation is usually
determine that yeah that's usually the
most important decision you make right
so how much of your money goes into the
stock market
is usually more important than which
individual stock you actually pick
which a lot of people don't understand
that but but that's definitely true and
so what you want to do is you just want
to make it super easy right i always
tell people like
just think of it if i have a hundred
dollars okay i want
twenty dollars to go to real estate i
want forty dollars to go to stocks i
want twenty dollars to go to crypto and
i want twenty dollars to sit in cash
let's just say that that's what you were
going to do
every time that you save a hundred
dollars you want it to almost be
automatic where just goes into those
investments almost think of your
investments
as your savings account right you just
keep putting money in to those
investments
over long periods of time so what that
means though is also you don't want to
pick things that are kind of
fad like right you don't want to say oh
zoom stock's flying right now let me go
put all my money in zoom
and then i'm gonna like time the market
and get out sure there's some people who
think that they're good at doing that by
the way most of them aren't
instead the best way to build wealth is
to have a very long-term
viewpoint and just to constantly put
money into the investments over a long
period of time
dollar cost average into them and just
allow compounding to work for you
and because you're a millennial you have
time still so your risk appetite
sorry the wind your risk your risk
appetite
should be larger than people in their
50s 60s 70s etcetera yeah
and and time is a really important point
because she's intolerance
she's right in that well you don't have
to have a higher risk tolerance you
should have a higher risk tolerance but
also it's just understanding if i let if
i let money compound for 30 years for
somebody who only can do it for 10
i have an advantage and so it just comes
down to uh people want to try to be too
smart but you don't need to be
smart you basically it's like it's kind
of like well warren buffett says you
just don't need to be an idiot
right and so it's like really really
simple the timeless personal finance
principles are timeless for a reason
next next jonathan as shittu
says who wins in a rap battle paulina or
anthony
my money's on pimp you want to go
you want to give me a beat come on go
do a rap battle there is a planet
doesn't even know how
to line words together yeah your name is
pop you just like i said like like i
just said
she literally came ain't nobody mess
with me because i am the original
p-i-m-p
oh that was pretty good all right next
question
well i i did it i gave my suggestion i
said p.i
i said go listen to big pimpin here what
about that question
um diogo you all want another song i got
another song goes in a lil wayne fire
man
okay diego oh my god diogo
rocha rosha okay says i have been
listening and reading a lot about
finances and i want to start a
newsletter to spread my still infant
knowledge of the markets crypto and
self-improvement
since i will be doing my it in my mother
tongue shout out portugal i think i have
a chance maybe this is not the best
question but how do i make my newsletter
profitable
thanks for everything you have taught me
and i agree with pomp cancel christmas
music though it wasn't you better read
that part
i wasn't gonna bring that all right i
like you already cancel christmas
only cancel christmas music before
thanksgiving i put my little tree up
over there
so it's a plan it's not a treat uh
the best way to think about this is
there's two different ways to make money
generally with newsletters one is you
can get people to pay you for it so
subscription model
or two is you can do ads uh the thing
that i always tell people is don't worry
about how you're gonna make money
at first just get started like just
start writing the email
uh and start sending it and starting to
build the audience and what you'll
quickly realize is like if you have a
huge
audience and you think that okay if i
make this uh subscription based let's
say on substack
about five to ten percent of people will
convert to pay right so
just use the assumption of five percent
well if you only have a hundred people
there's only five people paying you
right it's really not going to be that
profitable
so actually what you may need to do is
you may need to go and get ads in order
to make it profitable and so it's hard
to kind of say like what you should do
my best advice is just get started
actually start building the audience and
then you can even ask them like you can
run a server and say hey
would you rather this be a subscription
with no ads or would you rather see ads
that are
you know timely and uh helpful and also
i think
before you even start thinking about
making the newsletter profitable you
should grow your audience and it sounds
like um if you're doing it in portuguese
you could look up some of the bigger
influencers or content creators
uh who have portuguese like uh
newsletters or publications et cetera
and try to get in front of their
audiences as well
um but i i think that's a great idea
absolutely
all right anything else that's it lil
wayne fireman see you guys
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five's my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends